my point was but here comes two million
people which is about
98 of the market when it's all said and
done
and they're gonna have different rules
you've got your perspective i just want
to be happy don't you want to be happy
[Music]
we appreciate you coming on i know
you're a busy man so we definitely
appreciate it
um to be honest i did not expect you to
reply to that dm to be on here
you know it's funny tyler i uh i get a
thousand two thousand three thousand a
day a week
you know i get bombarded and i just
think it's i think it's super important
to give back
and what i mean by that is and i don't
want this to sound like i think i'm
special
or i'm a douche but like i'm aware
that my 30 minutes is really hard for me
has a lot of value for me
and that by doing this show i feel like
i first of all i love this [ __ ] card
thing
so it's fun but two yeah but two
i'm not naive i know that this is a big
get and will probably
springboard your podcast in a real way
will lead to you
being have more juice in the game and i
think that's cool like that
i'm like flattered that blows me away
from where i came from
that i could do something like be on
someone's show and it actually means
something
makes me happy and i'm happy to be here
thanks for inviting me oh of course we
definitely appreciate it
so i guess we'll dive right into the to
the first question i'm not gonna be a
total [ __ ] to you i know i've been a
big
uh he's he saves that for us
yeah exactly you know what the good news
is bro honestly
i i don't don't struggle with much like
i don't i you know it's funny i i don't
i don't think
any i don't think persistence is [ __ ]
i don't think people that
initially think i'm a dick is [ __ ] i
really don't i
i'm i'm deeply understanding of the
human psyche
so a lot of things make sense to me so
i'm you can ask me a million questions
i'm here for you let's rock and roll
whatever you want
all right i guess let's dive right in so
how do you feel about people
taking your words to the extreme when it
comes to cards we call it the gary vee
effect
like if you post a card right and
immediately on ebay it jumps
it triples in price i think about in a
couple ways
one i worry about it because i know that
i'm going to be the
800th most followed person talking about
sports cards in 24 months
right the first place that my brain goes
when you ask that question is
what's that gonna look like when it's
dwyane wade or
when it's you know two chains or or when
it's
you know ryan reynolds so like that that
is the first thing that my mind goes
into which is
that number two i worry
because if you look at the history of
every single player
i have mentioned in any shape or form
the track record
of their actual on-field play
is extraordinarily high outside of
injury right like
yeah yeah darren fox got banged up but
honestly i have more conviction about
darren fox today than i did even then
right so like
you know like when people like first of
all when people talk about me pumping
and dumping i haven't sold a single card
very hard to be pump and dump when you
don't have the dump part
makes sense number two the people that i
talk about
like like it blows my mind that and i'm
very aware of what i've posted
and i don't put i mean i want to post 13
times a day about players and cards
yeah but i do it once every 13 weeks
because i'm aware of what's happening
um i you know i don't think it's a
stretch to be excited about
mookie betts or devin booker or luka
donagh or lebron
or giannis like these would be like like
you know it's not like i'm talking about
like
i haven't said a word about the
following people zion
high risk in my opinion because of
production
thank you no but but could turn out to
be unbelievable because he's a [ __ ]
beast but
high risk wasn't interesting for me to
talk about you've not seen a single
word out of my mouth about jason
dominguez when people
[ __ ] on me on twitter i go look at their
accounts they're [ __ ] on me
on like talking about devin booker or
or or luca thank you for poker and
they're [ __ ]
talking about jason dominguez and wander
franco do you know how much of a true
gamble that is
yeah it's a gamer so yeah dominguez is
16 right now and people are dropping
like a bentley on him
correct so to me i'm aware of it which
is why i've evolved i wasn't aware of it
at first
then i became like oh by the way acuna
and juan soto
like i don't know feeling pretty fine
with that
yeah you know what like but once i
started seeing certain things happen
post that i definitely got into a place
of like and you've seen it i've blurred
i'm trying different things i've
blurred the the card because i want to
talk about cards
because i love it but i don't want to do
that i've
you know it feels scarier to me
you know the number one thing i'm
settling in is if i'm gonna talk about a
card
i'm gonna probably talk about how much i
own at that moment
because i've never owned i don't own a
lot i'm you know like
like it's not like i've never owned like
a drillion cards of it like i've always
been up like
pretty upfront like win with me
or lose with me yeah or what i really
want which is don't listen to me listen
to yourself
yeah and that's that's one thing i like
to preach and i probably preach a lot of
it is
people to think for themselves not
listen
to everybody that has money just
do what you do you don't need to listen
to everybody my
objective here is to be remarkably
historically correct
yeah yeah like like my objective is to
like that's right
like i want like i want people to see
the receipts of when i told people to
buy luca thirty five bucks
yeah yeah honestly 160 like that's real
like
everybody [ __ ] on me on being big on
lebron chrome
but i was like cards are about to
explode a lot of money's going to come
in
lebron's lebron there's 2 000 psa 10
chrome base
like this is just going to make sense
and so when it went from
you know 900 bucks or a thousand to like
three four thousand everyone's like this
is
[ __ ] no chance well here we are
where it's like you know today it's like
13
8 14 2. god forbid he wins this
championship
or another one before he's done
you know i don't know i
my biggest struggle is that a lot of the
criticism
comes from places where they're doing
the same actions
against far higher risk thoughts
yeah yeah yeah me while pumping bobo
feels feels very hypocritical
the only difference between me and
anybody else is i have a bigger audience
so i understand and respect that person
who has
1400 followers who's [ __ ] on me but
then pumps volvo
because when he or she pumps bubble the
market doesn't
think or debate it as much so i
understand it
but if you're gonna [ __ ] on me for
sharing who i think is good
you might want to look that i've stayed
very narrow
across seven to 12 people from
youth and basically 80 vintage
which is just pure supply and demand in
art form
and has been historically correct now
for 70 years
you've done well with mantle and hodness
wagner you've lost on mike greenwell
right and you know and glenn
and glenn robinson you know what i mean
you know like
and so i feel good about what i'm doing
don't forget
i did this before a lot of people were
born so i learned my lessons on todd van
popple
and browning people and i've learned my
lessons of what everybody's doing with
michael porter jr and that's not to say
michael porter jr is going to be good or
not and that's not saying that
if he goes off like he's been doing in
the bubble that you won't get that
short-term spike
but somebody's going to be left sitting
with the bag
oh yeah and to me if you hit mickey
mantle
and michael jordan you're okay with
sitting with the bag because it goes
down 10 20 percent when things are rough
not 90 percent and i feel very confident
in buying vintage basketball with
basketball's global popularity
that when it's not as hot as it is right
now
in three weeks or three months or three
years or 13 years
then i'm not going to be devastated
sitting with george gervin high grade
rookies or moses malone or dr
j because they'll go down but they're
not going to zero
there's a lot of people tyler hero bull
ball michael porter jr devonte graham
three or four of those guys are going to
zero yeah
or yeah zero i mean
three bucks for the psa 10 psa 10
graded at the bottom of the next cycle
eight years from now when they didn't
end up being good because they got hurt
or they just didn't end up being good
and card's demand is super soft like at
its softest that it's been in a decade
all of a sudden that's a 3 10 12 card
yeah when it's at the same bottom of
that demand for dr j
rookie psa 8 it goes from 10k to maybe
7k
6k it'll never be back at 100 bucks like
it was this has been a shift
just like mantle and honest wagner and
gretzky rookies had a shift
in the mid 80s to 90s when the last
massive shift in sports card collecting
i think this will be the biggest shift
of them all
i really do i think this will be a
bigger era than 86 to 93.
uh and i think that's because of 86 to
93 because you have the 45 50 year olds
like me that have money so we're going
all in in perpetuity
i'm holding on to my bill russell high
grade 57 tops
until i die oh absolutely yeah
you have everyone in this era learning
from the 90s in the junk wax era
they're not though nate let me explain
they are and they're not
let me explain the modern everyone's
so obsessed what happens when cards get
super hot
is you gamble you dream
and you watch let me say one more time
you gamble
buying high-end packs to pull the zion
yeah more fun than being
strategic and buying clyde directs or
8687 flea or psa 9
right you dream all of a sudden
you know dominguez and wander and nolan
gorman
and you know bull bowl are going to be
[ __ ] stan usual
and [ __ ] wilt chamberlain so you
dream
and then you watch it's a lot more fun
to do the first two things
because we can watch them on espn and
cbs
and fox sports you can't watch clyde
drexler
no yeah so so nate i don't i am
i believe that a lot of people are going
to lose
because i think they're going to go long
and
what we haven't seen yet right now we
are in hyper hot
it's like oh yeah we're in you can't
lose
mode right now what's gonna happen is
i think there's gonna be a lot of
maturity and evolution over the next 12
to 24 months
what will happen is look by the way even
in our hyper hot
i know a lot of guys who lost a ton of
money on baker mayfield last year yep
oh yeah me too collector trust me i know
what you're talking about
so so we are in the hottest of hot of
hot
and yet you can still lose on baker
lamar jackson breaks his leg in week one
people are gonna lose money on lamar
jackson of tied up money
yeah goes to zero but if you're in for
1300 and you expect 3000 and now it's at
640
and you don't want to sell because he's
still young and has upside
or you have to sell because you need
liquid because i mean 90
95 percent of this hobby doesn't have 99
including me doesn't have unlimited
resources to buy in forever
yeah yeah so so i don't know nate the
amount of prism
that is being printed you know which
zion psa tends to be when it's all said
and done
i meant more so we are still seeing
the supply or the demand exceed the
supply you can't find
anything anywhere correct you know
they're ramping it up to an extent
bro they ramped it bro you know much
more luca
yeah there wasn't a year before and how
much more zion there was than luca
five [ __ ] a [ __ ] ton because they know
they're printing money
that's right jack but your nate your
point is right and this is by the way
this is why i ended up being right about
what i've been yelling about for the
last two years
i have always been good at knowing
demand
social media e-commerce then within
social media
snapchat tick-tock this is what i do
it's just weird that it stumbled on
something i once loved and knew cold for
a decade
i i waited six months before i said a
[ __ ] thing i'm like
i think sports cards are about to get
insane insane insane insane
and then i lay there for six months
saying am i just trying to trick myself
because i love this [ __ ]
yeah and like then am i gonna look
stupid to your point nate
we're not even close yet to the demand
explosion being done
but when it settles and when half these
rookies i mean
right now every day and by the way i
love it because all you [ __ ] 13 17 23
31 year olds you're me so i love
watching all the kids doing their thing
but guys colin sexton is probably not
gonna be one of the 25 greatest players
of all time
and you're gonna kind of need him to be
if you're long colin sexton
at the prices he is right now and i
brought up colin sexton so imagine
how much [ __ ] we're talking about yeah
oh yeah yeah
i'm just happy to mention bull bull
because that was the funniest [ __ ] to me
he scored 60 points in the scrimmage and
everyone loses their minds
well it wasn't even a it wasn't even
what he did in that full scrimmage it
was a single
highlight yeah a single high age like
that wow
it was a really nice three pointer
better spend six grand on an nt rpa
guys the amount of money historically in
the next 15 years that are gonna be lost
on
nt rpas is gonna be staggering yes oh
yeah absolutely
it's already getting here no but like
ridiculous but it's really predicated on
the kid
because if the kid turns out to be a
hall of famer you won't
yeah if clarence davis becomes a [ __ ]
hall of famer
and the next kawhi leonard that his
crazy 700
for an rpa right now raw of a guy who
plays a little bit and shows flashes
in toronto becomes a steal the problem
is that's going to happen for two guys
and every other rpa that's 400 to 850 is
going to be a problem because guess what
as hyped as you were for luca then came
zion
and as hyped as you are for zion here
comes lamello
and and and all of that attention and
heat gets
amortized and gets split up and now
people are coming in full throttle
so people are cross-pollinating i've
been obsessed with vintage basketball
well guess what
it's forced me to look at vintage
football because i'm like wait a minute
if vintage basketball has gone up 30x
and this is what jerry west cost and
this is what bart starcost and they were
even but now jerry west is 30 you know
like
four seven or 13 times like what that's
doing is making me look over there and
that's happening to everybody everyone's
like
people are crossing for pokemon to
basketball poke and basketball to
pokemon and soccer
to basketball and basketball to soccer
and baseball to soccer
and that all just stretches people
which means all of a sudden the sixth
super the sixth best rookie in this nba
class
now collapses in value because everyone
so also focused on the second best
soccer player
the rare shadowless first edition
pokemon a baseball player
old soccer here now we're gonna start
looking at i'm starting to look at comic
book cards from
the 50s 60s 70s 80s and 90s i'm like
wait a minute here come all the comic
book guys
won't they maybe want to do cards
somebody look at these old marble sets
upper deck just got the license will
that reboot marvel
should i be looking at oh batman 66 said
like like this is the [ __ ] that happens
yeah pretty much
nate so uh another one that we were
wondering do you see yourself as more of
a collector or an investor or like a mix
of the two
investor it's just the truth
and i know that everybody there's people
that feel that you're not allowed to do
that
yeah you have to be a hobbyist and like
i don't want to lie
like in between 1993 and 2000 you know
17 when i got you know i collected you
know i bought a bunch of 90
frank thomas's because it was my card i
have some name
or stuff but but the truth is that's 10
to 12 percent of my energy
and 88 90 is investor
you know and i and you know i think
that's okay because that's
america's freedom right like you're
supposed to be okay nobody owns your
perspective in the same way that i very
much
am deeply empathetic with people that
are collectors only
who are struggling in this era because
everything got expensive that makes
sense it
sucks yeah yeah i use the
investing part of cards to pay for my
collecting part of cards i totally
understand
it's all self-sustaining and that's
awesome and i used my investing side of
cards eventually when i transact how i
transact
to donate money to pencils of promise
because i want to
make sure that people in africa have
schools or to
be able to pay my employees more so i
can take less of a base salary
like like everyone's allowed to do
whatever the [ __ ] they want yeah
i collect the arizona cardinals so i
just sit back and lose money it's kind
of tradition
i don't know about that bro if right now
i i mean i i think
deandre hopkins larry fitzgerald rookies
are underpriced and i think
tyler murray is a real guy yeah i i
still don't know how he got hopkins i i
was huge on yeah i love david johnson i
love him to death he's a great guy
once i saw he got deandre hopkins i said
bye that's why
jonathan's a running back in a different
part of his career than hopkins i mean
that's
kenyon's been playing great when he came
here too we don't need to drink honestly
yeah yeah that's fair yeah so special of
in investing uh there's a bunch of
especially on instagram of these like
investment pages that
will offer tips in order for what money
like pay them and they'll give you tips
on investing
uh what's your take on those types of
pages you know
i think it's very similar to what
happens in wall street the question
becomes
if enough people pay them and they all
listen does that in fact then drive the
market
while there's lower supply yes once this
gets
leveled out no um look i
you know i feel really i feel like i'd
be very good if that was my business i'm
very good at sports i've done very well
fantasy and i've done very well at
sports cards when i was a kid
kenny lofton frank thomas like i really
did well
um so look and i think that helps people
make money like some people just go with
emotion and if you have an
analytical strong mind so i i think that
like everything in life 20 of those
things are probably fantastic and 80
of them are straight garbage okay yeah
that's about what they're saying i will
take that
it's just the people who like say you
pay them to say hey
buy my cards what's the point that's the
thing right like for example
i'll never do this but if i did that
everybody would sign up because
everybody would be like well he has so
much leverage that it's like you know
what i mean like
yeah yeah i assume and i don't know any
of the i don't know any of the services
something weird about me is like i'm so
focused
on coming up with the ideas
that seize opportunities that nobody
else sees
that i'm not spending as much time
figuring out who
is the who's who of our industry i want
to be friends with everybody in it
yeah but i spent 100 of my time looking
at population reports against perceived
demands against
human psychology against twitter
conversations and thoughts and this like
i'm trying to learn
yeah there's a lot to take in is
because i'm not worried about [ __ ]
like fighting on twitter
or trying to scam i'm like trying to do
real work and be like
wait a minute there's only uh there's
only 300
hakeem elijah won psa 10 86 fleer
rookies in the world
and if he's a true top 15 player
basketball is going to truly do this
and wait a minute africa being the next
continent that is going to get
globalized the way asia did
this might be a good 25-year play like
that's what i'm doing
yeah i think more people are focused on
listening to these accounts they're
listening part way into the process
rather than learn who to invest in learn
how to
invest that's what the kids need by the
way anybody who
does anything about anything who's an
active young player
is complete gambling derek was 100
right this is why i think there's a much
more strategic
thing to be done with vintage than there
is with current
if you can anticipate demand you have
boxed in supply with pop numbers and
it's not in wax
and you know what they did in their
career that's why i love the aba players
because they're better than people
realize because they don't have
their mba stats reflect their aba but i
also thought that this was going to
explode
and that 50 year olds know who moses
malone and george gervin are
and they're gonna want it just like i
wanted frank thomas you see where i'm
going
it all makes sense this is like common
sense this isn't
i'm right you should 100 invest in gary
trent jr
you have no control over that you could
be 100 right and gary trent jr
could end up becoming the next grand
hill and get hurt all the time
yep for the next four years and then
using grand hill
may then still miraculously have an
incredible career do you understand
how right you would have been about sean
livingston if we this was the year of
sean livingston coming out but
we didn't know that was he was destined
for so many injuries that he could only
be a shell of what he would have been
yeah do the kids understand or the
grown-ups
what kind of players sean livingston
would have been if those injuries didn't
happen
no he was great all-time great he was
phenomenal
scary different every investment is a
gamble
when you look at it no matter what it is
fair enough but
but what i will tell you is when the nba
has 75th anniversary next year and you
know they did a 50th anniversary
you know top 50 players of all time and
you can kind of anticipate that they're
going to do top 75 players for this year
and you know that tim duncan is a top 10
player of all time
yet his card because the hobby didn't
like it or him all i heard two years ago
the hobby doesn't like to dunk it the
hobby doesn't like peyton manning the
hobby only likes quarterbacks
i'm like that makes sense i respect that
the hobby is the current state of demand
yes my point was but here comes two
million people
which is about 98 of the market when
it's all said and done
and they're going to have different
rules
i mean i think the rookie the card
that's considered the rookie
is going to be one of the great things
to watch over the next decade
that i'm personally interested to see
as the influx comes in um
negro league players have been
underpriced for years
agreed and i'm just waiting for that to
take
i for me i agree with that comma
i think baseball is the most mature
market
oh absolutely you know baseball's mature
when we go to the national or other
sports card shows the 50
70 year old guys you know it's i'm sure
the kids razz on them
and they razz on the kids they just look
at vintage baseball
that's why i think vintage basketball
was such an opportunity
because i thought the next generation of
me is because i know all the 40 and 50
60 year olds that are balling and really
really call it 50 and on 50 to 35
they're basketball yeah and all of a
sudden
like do you understand that ernie banks
i'm just looking at this homework
ernie banks's rookie and jerry west's
rookie have basically the same amount of
psa eights i think
was i comparing it might be seven don't
hold me to this they basically have the
same amount
right of of supply but ernie banks's
rookie it was
2x and and jerry west is moving so fast
that
yeah this might be a little because it
was a couple weeks ago but it was 2x
and that's when i said bingo i go
basketball is the culture this guy's the
[ __ ] logo this guy drafted [ __ ]
kobe when there's a jerry west
documentary of how his impact on the nba
maybe one of the greats of all time logo
and drafting kobe puts you right there
besides what he did on the court how the
[ __ ] is there any
no [ __ ] i mean listen cubs nation's
huge i love bernie banks my best friend
brandon's a
cubs fan i bought him an ernie banks
rookie i think or hey he made me send it
back and it's the best but
nonetheless it's not going to be 2x
jerry west is going to be two x ernie
banks so that's why
i do like the negro league stuff but i
also i would i also am obsessed with
civil rights leaders
ali jim brown yeah russell karim because
obviously our
our country is becoming more thoughtful
about that and that's one that's
interesting not to mention those are
like four
all-time top 100 athletes so you know
a lot of interesting stuff to think
about for sure
so how do you see you kind of answered
this when
after the first question what do you see
this hobby
transforming into over the next few
years
you know look there's uh we just had a
major pandemic
yeah there's a lot of people out of a
job the macroeconomic
situation is vulnerable we have a very
contentious election
um nobody knows what the global economy
or the us economy is going to do
and look if we go into a massive
recession sports carts
are not something you eat or put over
your head when it rains
so you can anticipate some of that i
think that's a vulnerability
taking that and putting it on a shelf if
not for that if we still have stability
in the macro in the micro of the macro
sports card world
i think we're very early it's happening
by the second
i mean it's an everyday thing that
there's a big headline
all everybody's listening right now and
i'm sure for you three every day
right now a friend in your life that
isn't into this
is now starting to ask you about it and
want to get in instead of making fun of
you about it
yep yeah yeah pretty much especially
after the lebron
and the mike trout yep
those sales yep a card sells for what
3.4 million people take note
and honestly honestly the normal kid is
still not gonna think like they can find
three four
i think it's adam lefko putting cards on
the tnt thing
it's you know i got a lot of kids
following me a lot you know steve aoki
there's just a million things going on
right now uh uh
pack breaking on youtube like and this
is why i'm bullish long term
every seven what nobody's talking about
is the seven eight and nine year olds
that consume youtube all day that are
watching pack breaking
all day like girls were watching makeup
videos yeah
yeah so there's a real big seven eight
nine year old crew
that's seven or eight years away from
really making noise
so keep that in mind
yeah so a segment that we normally have
on our show
is called baking biscuits where we talk
about we like to be crazy and everything
instead of grind our gears we say what
[ __ ] our biscuits
so is there anything in the sports world
that [ __ ] your biscuits
that means pisses me off yeah yeah
in the sports card world sports cards
yes um
you know what this doesn't [ __ ] with me
i'm empathetic to it but i think it's
dangerous
because it leads to contention instead
of happiness because everyone should be
getting along
and enjoying it's when people think
their opinion of what other people
should do
is right yeah yeah
yeah that same thing applies to just the
world in general
it sure does my friend but but i think
all of us in the hobby world right now
recognize that the amount of time that
people say
well people should or start a sentence
with
well nobody should or start with you
shouldn't
i just you can say things instead like i
don't like win
yeah but but that's really like to me if
you're in the business of
talking about i don't like when
then you're wasting energy on focusing
on i like to
yeah okay right like like there's a
million things that i don't like
i don't like i didn't say a single thing
of project 2020.
yeah that's true you know i didn't
i was asked a million times i didn't
want to listen i don't want to [ __ ] on
tops because i thought it was clever i
love the artists i don't want to [ __ ] on
that
it wasn't for me it's not how i see
things i think those are things that are
going to go up
and down quickly it seems to me that
that's what's happened in that
with that stuff like you know i don't
like i don't like
people i mean people like i think every
rookie is a vulnerability all of them
all of them i think tops in prison and
panini are making a lot of cards right
now
and and bowman is [ __ ] complete
gambling
yes oh absolutely yes gambler's product
and that's by the way that's awesome
because i think going atlantic city
and spending a hundred thousand dollars
of yours and winning or losing it
is your prerogative i think there's a
lot of entitlement
and people that think that you know i've
had some kids in their late 20s
have great combos with me of like you're
not doing this right [ __ ] you today i'm
like dude
you're like awesome and i love you and i
got love and like let's be friends but
like
straight up i was selling cards [ __ ]
every single day of my life
when you were [ __ ] sperm in your
dad's dick
[Laughter]
you're not struggling right now you're
doing all right it's not about
struggling
i would never pull the i'm what no no
i'm talking about
you're telling me that you're right
because you were here before me
and i'm reminding you that i was here
before you okay
yeah got it this has nothing to do with
i've been successful so [ __ ] you
this has been you came at me and said
you're doing this wrong [ __ ] you you're
[ __ ] this
up as if you're the gatekeeper of it
when
i was doing it for a decade before you
were born or when you were bored
no that makes perfect sense yeah and by
the way i i have no interest in saying
that to
any kid that's been doing it for last
eight years as a matter of fact
i love befriending all these kids
because i missed a decade of context
and that's how i learned over the last
three years i'm like what happened with
when the [ __ ] did when did he come why
why did
why didn't wait a minute when i was
every brand had every card oh
exclusive what did upper deck do what
the [ __ ] is it what's trimming what's
grading
it started with for me cause i i left
right before grading going like so
you know like i understand all of it i
respect
everyone i am not upset that i get so
much
judgment heat love hate because i have a
very big platform and that's comes with
the territory
i feel great about who i am i feel
anybody that's actually met me or
transacted know what i'm about as a
human
i've tried to do nothing wrong i've been
unbelievably
cautious to make sure that i don't do
anything that upsets anybody or does
anything wrong
i i i'm flattered when people think i'm
driving it i understand that it drives
up but like
the reality is people love to point be
like what about mookie backstabber
i'm like what about every other too
and again it's one thing if i'm sitting
out here and saying like
hey nolan gorman who by the way i think
is a nice prospect
a nice prospect who could be a good
baseball player
it's not like i'm putting out videos
like nolan gorman is going to be [ __ ]
my trout and his bowmen
go through the [ __ ] roof that's
reckless
that i'm saying you know i'm saying it
about mookie bats
and devin booker and why they say about
mookie bits because they compared him
and his card to trout and harper
and bellinger and i'm just looking at
comps
again all day long [ __ ] gary b this and
that and then you go to their page
yo you got to get on dominguez
the bull bowl hype it never ends it's
still going michael
michael instagram loves michael porter
jr and that man is a walking injury
report
yeah and by the way it's hard not to
like him when you watch him play like
he's played the last couple days but
people forget that that's a moment in
time
and i remind people that derrick rose
looked like a [ __ ] top 15 player of
all time they're still injuries bo
jackson in 1990
hardaway penny hard away like you know
there's unlimited examples of this
and by the way then you've got other
guys who dominated well joshua didn't
have
he had the hype in but he didn't have
the success on the field let me give you
other success on the field but their
cards are not worth a fortune do you
understand how hot white hot stephon
marbury was
at one point what's his cars you know
like you understand
you know like how hot like you know
great all-time ray allen is
all-time great he's in the top 100 yet
yeah
his rookie cards are less than [ __ ]
bull ball
[Laughter]
i think i think people over correct to
the new and under correct to the old so
i've been very consistent
because i don't want to look like a fool
and i'm old now and i made those
mistakes as a kid
vintage vintage vintage and then look
for arbitrage within vintage like like
i'll share things i'm looking i'm like i
keep looking at tim hardaway senior
you know i'm like man he was a really
fun good player he shouldn't be
25 to 50 cents raw for his flea rookie
yeah now i only think that goes to five
to 12 bucks but like
you know by the way but by the way
i'm so worried that cards are so
expensive i think a lot of people are
going to have to find those things
you know that's why that's why i collect
what i collect
i'm sure you've seen my page i collect
hall of fame stuff
i'm not throwing money into investments
i just collect what i enjoy what i
collected as a kid it's not meant as a
razz but i'm using this platform to
explain how i roll
i haven't looked at your page i don't
know anything
i'm just i'm spending all my time doing
real homework on the macro not the micro
yeah you'd be stunned how little i know
of every mover and shaker i know
i know a lot about you now that i like
you and we're having a nice time here
but i have no idea who's the collector
who's an investor who's the flipper
who's not
who's vintage who's not who's the who's
associated with who like i know nothing
i focus on my [ __ ] yeah
there's so much to keep track of it's
impossible to keep track of everything
that's right
and i will and i want to win so like i'm
spending a lot of time on looking at
mookie bets do i think he's going to get
a contract
um you know like what do i think is
going to happen in that dodgers lineup
short season how young is he what you
know what's his war like
like who is he as a human what's he
going to do after baseball
like a-rod jack d-wade people that stay
in the media
a lot more interesting potentially than
let's say a dirk no
you know what i mean like like you have
to pay attention to what happens next if
you're playing long i'm here for long
uh do you have enough time to ask you
one more question gear yeah ironically i
i i tried to make a little extra buffer
time because i wanted i knew i was going
to have fun so let's keep
let's keep brewing figured
so what's the card you want the most
like what's your white whale the one you
treasure the most that you don't have
i would probably say the highest grade
george biking in the world okay
i like that i'll tell you why i think
it's the
i think it's been very clear where i sit
on basketball cards and vintage
specifically
and the 48 bowman mike in is kind of
like the hoeness wagner
for basketball cards yeah there's
actually you know what i'm going to
change that a little bit as well there's
also a set
a 1968 tops test basketball set that is
incredibly rare
that i'd love to have i've none i'd love
to have some
um
uh i'm i'm extremely hot
on there's one set that's re a modern
set that's
kaboom's inserts have my attention
so i've been spending a lot of time
lately on
what's the modern thing that i can feel
focused on
because i've been talking right what can
i focus on and by the way i'm gonna
focus on players
now they're gonna have to show me at
least a season and i'm gonna have to
know who they are off the field
and i'm gonna have to project and i'm
gonna have to pray that they don't get
hurt
that's why you heard acuna soto booker
from me
got it yeah luca right like that's right
yeah by the way when i talked about
giannis that was the year before he blew
out
so like i was i did a good job with that
one that's why i was a buck 60. so like
so that's what i'm going to always look
for but then i've also been looking for
like
are there any inserts any brands any off
shoots is there anything weird
and the one that i'm kind of starting to
zero in on is kaboom and i'll tell you
why and you heard it from me before
i believe comic book culture is coming
to cars
and i think that two things will benefit
from it
vintage comic book cards the old batman
and the 60 set the marvel for 90. you
know like comic book cards i mean
yeah and i think this is early and i'm
surprised i'm even sharing it because
usually i'll only share because i don't
want to be wrong
things that i'm like so i'm not
but the population numbers on kabooms
how hard they were to get how hard they
are to grade
the fact that they look like comics who
they are
the fact that there's now gold and green
of 10 of one
if you if i always think like this if i
went into a time machine
in 20 years and what was carrying an
uncomfortable amount of value
would i be surprised or would i not be
surprised and the one that really sticks
with me right now is kaboom
which what's your guys thought because
i'm still kind of baking any thoughts on
that
i personally love the kabooms because i
i come
from like a nerdy comic book background
that's why i love them i love the art
style
and like you said how hard they are to
get the same thing with the
prism color blast cards
i think that's good for me to hear
because that's my hypothesis comic book
land is coming
what are they going to focus on holy
[ __ ] is kaboom going to
really really scratch their itch mm-hmm
and look who it is right it's [ __ ]
top rookies top superstars
best you know starters basketball
obviously is involved but like
who's in it is [ __ ] epic and it's
super comic [ __ ] the first stuff the
2013 stuff was straight drawings
it's evolved a little bit um yeah i'm
hot on it
and i've got probably like 40 50 right
now mixed
raw and graded this back to me like i
just realized i went pretty far down
this rabbit hole so let me be
transparent
rabbit hole yeah go for it you know what
i mean if i'm gonna do public shows now
i want to be a little bit i don't know
my exact number but it feels about 40 to
50 which is not a lot
you know like like in a scheme of like
like this whole pump and dump thing
drives me crazy
like that rap because because i
understand it because
i could literally do it every day um
but i just haven't done it so that like
you know
yes and so i think by sharing my numbers
of what i'm holding when i talk about
things
it might help people have a sense people
forget
how much business wealth i have outside
of this world
yeah like like the thought of like
amassing five thousand
let me say this number five thousand
rookie bets
to then put out a post and then flip
them is the great
waste of my time
you know i you know one guy really went
at me and i just finally said to him
because he
like i was really not he was not being
nice and we were one on one i was like
bro
i get paid 150 000 to give a speech
like for me to make 150 000 on devin
booker i would have had about this many
out of
like bought them all flipped them all
like like it just
i don't think people realize why would i
ruin my reputation
for economics that are big for them but
not big for me that's not smart
the same way that people that are way
bigger than me wouldn't do things
that i would do right for say right yeah
so i just wish people were a little more
thoughtful and i wish people
what's nice though is now i've been in a
little while and a lot of people have
dealt with me and i think
i don't know if you guys have heard
maybe you can tell me or not tell me
don't make it up to make me feel good
but i think people are starting to get a
sense of my
kindness humanity what kind of guy i am
that i'm actually in it
i would say personally i know when you
you first came in it's one of those
things
change people are a lot of people are
scared of it i know all three of us were
a little
wary at first i'll be honest i was very
skeptical in the beginning
i'm very skeptical i i appreciate the
candor keep going and at last year's
national i was helping
work at a friend of mine's booth and you
came up and you're buying cards from him
and right then just how you interacted
with him i was
sold right then because you were just
genuine
interesting thank you and i will say
this gary i know i've been one of the
biggest i guess
basher of yours but
i appreciate how i forget when he posted
it was a few weeks ago when he posted
the cards and he blurred it all out
i do appreciate that just because i'm
trying things look
i'll be honest with you it really stinks
because i'm excited like who wants to
blur their [ __ ] cards
yeah yeah but i'm trying listen i love
this community
i would like i it was my life
like you understand every moment i
breathe
air from 1985 86 to 1993
was spent thinking about the becket
going to card shows
setting up like it was my life
yeah yeah so i mean i mean i had so much
fun
at the nat like i literally cried
at the national like i when i tell you
i'm gonna
lose my mind at next year's chicago
national and happiness
yeah like it's gonna be like a party
i can't oh yeah i'm excited i can't wait
for it because that's the only time
i actually don't even know like i'd love
to hear it actually since
what was this cynicism was it what what
did you think
and this is now fun because we're in a
different place what do you think like
i'm curious what you think i wanted to
do
my criticism wasn't necessary from you
it was from the people who took your
word as
gospel and tried to push exactly
that's happening to me in my real
business life world a lot of people hear
only part of the equation yes and then
they go and run with
that and then they get loud and they
annoy people
yes thank you that makes sense
if you hear a kid drop the f-bomb
and you ask where they heard it from and
then you blame where they heard it from
not necessarily the kid
yeah i totally totally totally it makes
a ton of sense
ty tyler what about you what was your
thought it's pretty much exactly what
what jack said it's worse is it one of
these things where
there was a bunch you guys are in it now
all of something comes this new breed
the only thing they know is what they're
parroting from my content or maybe one
other place
and they're trying to impose on you when
you've been putting in the work it
for three four six years and you know
what you're quote-unquote talking about
pretty much basically i've been in this
hobby i'm 30 years old i've been doing
this literally
since i was born my dad's collected for
50 years
i think i genuinely have an idea of
what's going on
and then all of a sudden you got people
telling you yeah like
to do this to do that and that's just
not my thing is it obvious to you
that it was happening for the six to 18
months prior
to me getting loud about it that the
momentum
started building how do you see that
tyler
and it was a little bit you could you
could tell that there was an influx
coming you just didn't know when it was
going to come
and then the first video i can't
remember what you posted what the first
video was
but then when i saw that first video my
first reaction was oh [ __ ] here we go
and sure enough that's when everybody
started coming in everybody started
cycling in
just making money spending money like
it was nothing and it it was a sight to
see
i'll give you that but it was something
that uh
was pretty surprising well let's let's
remind everybody for the sake of the
conversation
that was two over two years ago and yes
and and that was a lot of money coming
in from your perspective
based on the base of that time those are
micro numbers compared to where we are
oh yeah most definitely a lot of people
like gary you're gonna make people lose
all this
i'm like i don't think you understand
the people that listened to me two years
ago
have already made more than everything
they can lose on their inventory
yeah pretty much i just found it crazy
how the pandemic made the card market
boom the way it did i wouldn't have
expected that
then you realize yeah all they have to
do is buy cards
and jack you'll love this every time
somebody's like gary you you i'm like
let me tell you something
i was this is why you can never win when
you have a big platform i was criticized
march april may in may on social
for not talking about cards for three
months
like you remember that you guys are yeah
i do not remember oh [ __ ] this c
see this is the place he's out he's out
now and he probably sold all his acunias
i have every one of them my safe like
meanwhile what was happening was the
hobby exploded during that time
i had a company to make sure didn't go
out of business
i started a non-profit execution called
the all-in challenge and raised 61
million dollars
to feed the hungry i was doing noble
things
yet getting [ __ ] on for not like
do you know how sad it is to be in a
place where you lose no matter what
you talk and you [ __ ] you don't talk and
you're [ __ ]
you talk and you're the reason it's
exploding in the same
sentence somebody goes the hobby
exploded during covet i didn't say [ __ ]
during the first three months of kobe
because i was trying to
do the things i just said i was doing so
how the [ __ ] do you win
plus with the amount of homework that
you put in we're seeing new trends
we're seeing a lot of the of the similar
trends that you were predicting before
but we're seeing
new trends come about so that time off
could have also been interpreted as you
doing homework as to new trends and keep
up with those
yeah i'm sharing the real truth here
which is like i was just trying to do
good for the world and make sure
my obligations were okay and to your
point nate
i i wish i bought on the things i
believed then during that time because
once i picked my head back up
in like june july when i went to go buy
vintage it already started moving
and now like the cat's out of the bag
it's just too
obvious by the way if gary vaynerchuk
never existed
all you youngsters that are real like
kind of operators from an investing
standpoint not collecting
would have all gravitated there
eventually anyway because it's the
actual answer to the test
yeah yeah there's no problem with that
just like tyler's dad and
and i don't know if he's just pure
collector like but having 50 years
experience
like let me tell you this the old men
let's call it what it is that were
talking to me in the mall
of edison new jersey in 1992 about
carl and shrimsky and fred lynn and get
them in nice shape
you know back then there was no talk
about centering it was corners and
creases
and i'm like [ __ ] these guys it's all
todd van poppo
you know what these guys don't get it
things that peop things that my friends
said around me when i got back in
they're like gary nobody gives a [ __ ]
about
will chamberlain they care about zion
i'm like okay
because i already lived people telling
me to buy pete rose and and roberto
clemente
and instead i decided to buy 4 000 david
justice rookie cards yeah
so like you know one of the things that
was fun for me nate at the national
was because you know again you saw i was
there as a dealer
and a part of the community yeah i
didn't have some fancy set like i was
i'm there i don't want that like i
turned down fancy from all the companies
there because
i actually have i want to do the show
yeah
what was really fun for me though is i
could feel the hobby get a different
sense with me because
i spent hours and hours talking and i
don't think people really realize how
much
i like lived cards like if you want to
talk about like 1984
to 1994 i know everything i know
everything i know everything about how
opici baseball came out was hot for five
minutes and then wasn't
i know everything about [ __ ] brian
taylor and greg jeffrey's and [ __ ] face
this and
mark race rookies two guys on the same
card i can go deep deep deep deep
yeah you know you know you want to talk
about [ __ ] wally joyner 87 tops i can
tell you what happened
you know that's a name i haven't heard
in a while
i think and i think that that i'm a
mature smart
successful operator at this point and
that's why a lot of things i'm saying i
feel great about i understand people's
cynicism i understand people's concerns
this bubble will burst
because every market goes up and down
and when
when it bursts no matter how i've said
it no matter how like this was a great
interview i appreciate it like no matter
how clear i've been
i'm prepared for many people to blame me
i just know how it works
yeah you know there will be literally
guys who [ __ ] made hundreds of
thousands to millions of dollars during
the up
and when they lose half of it even
though they've made more than they've
ever made
will then turn and blame me because they
didn't heed
buying 86 87 clear they didn't heed
buying 61 clear basketball and 57 tops
football
and and basketball they didn't heed what
i was actually saying
and they let their emotions and greed
and gambling
and want of the short money make them go
to some 12 year old in peru and
that's why they're going to get caught
yeah
well we definitely appreciate you coming
on gary likes i know you're a busy man
so it means a lot to us that you came on
of course tyler
gang any what questions were on the
docket that we didn't get to let's do a
rapid fire
i can't do these often so i like to get
as much out to the universe as possible
and i like you guys you mind if i get
mine off just because i have one last
one
uh so we've seen like a bunch of people
like literally camping out at their
walmart's targets they'll bring chairs
they'll bring a book next to the retail
section
i get blamed for that a lot too flip
life i've seen all the blame
that's on walmart okay
nice cabbage patch kids and power
rangers existed too
all that walmart and target have to do
is put four per customer
and of course people will bring their
cousin and wife but it could be better
yeah yeah that's the result i'm seeing a
lot of people
really push for that limit per customer
so i'm glad to
see that you like that you should and by
the way and i don't blame the people
that
are going there and not limit per
customer because they're living their
life
that's you know capitalism like they're
trying to feed their family and then
this is what they
like is is your want of collecting
you know vlad guerrero junior inserts
that are only available at target
more valuable than another man or
woman's want to pay the mortgage for
their family and this is what they think
is the right thing to do
yeah it's hard this is who's right
you know like walmart like but don't
blame me
don't blame somebody who's trying to do
something for their family blame a
system
blame tops can do it on their website
direct to consumer with limits
so like let's get real here let's have a
conversation not
[ __ ] just spin venom at each other
yeah
also how was planning for tops was that
cool like was that a quote
i remember one of the one of the people
that dislikes me the most is like he's
only here
i gotta pay 25 i would have paid them
20. i got paid 25k on the record
which again is an ungodly amount of
money but like just not for me at this
point in my career it's not why i did it
and i would have paid them 25k to have a
[ __ ] card are you kidding me
i was in top series too are you nuts
all right that's all i got you guys we
got four more minutes what else
what's going on the last question i had
for you was uh
what's your favorite hobby story
i'm obsessed when people find like uncle
bob or grandpa
johnny's like collection in the app like
i can't wait to garage sale like you
can't imagine tyler
yeah i'm like like kovid's killing me
because of the national
and because of garage sailing because
i'm going to garage sale like a mother
i'm going to buy like old books like a
thousand of them take them home
and open them like packs hoping somebody
slid a [ __ ]
you know will chamberlain 61 into their
book
i'm so fired up so i love those i love
the hunt
and i do love i do think the hobby is
going to evolve a little i think the
hobby will follow me not because
everyone's going to follow me
because they think i'm right or i'm
going to make them money i think they're
going to get to the same observations
that i have which is like
supply and demand matter and so so if
something's very rare whether manifested
by the card companies
or like everybody's accepted panini
making 10 of these
but yet they're letting things that only
have 10 population
and a rare sit undervalued yeah
your [ __ ] i i for a long time talked
about now it's finally moving and i'm
pissed because i've been
not paying attention and like in a month
it [ __ ] skyrocketed
but like but i know that i've mentioned
in the past so i'll bring it up i was
obsessed with the 1972 icy bear set
so there's like it's funny you say that
because my
that's one of my dad's favorite sets of
all time he actually bought a bunch of
them
not too long ago i got into the hobby
i'm doing my research i'm obsessed with
vintage basketball
it's expensive now it's [ __ ] i wish i
bought all of it
you know but i'm like these 72 first of
all i love nostalgia and marketing i'm a
marketing guy
so all the sugar daddy jack-in-the-box
you know
carvel discs from the set like all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] with me heavy
i'm into all of you yeah my dad loves
[ __ ] too
found a guy at the national i bought all
his [ __ ] he's like everyone thinks he's
junk i'm like i think it's gonna be more
valuable than the [ __ ] real [ __ ] and
i still do i think the 85 nike
jordan has a chance of being more
valuable than the [ __ ] 86 clear
jordan
because i think [ __ ] changes and supply
and demand matters
and these things are extremely rare and
they weren't manufactured rare
and then put into sleeves they're rare
because it wasn't manufactured and then
it got dinged the [ __ ] up
yep so more art and antique and i just
[ __ ] love that space so anyway
the thrill of the hunt mate two ways one
literally going
to a garage sale and buying binders of
first edition shadowless pokemon for a
great deal or finding
old magazines or findings you know some
of the hand-cut [ __ ] i'm like learning
i wish people knew how deep i was in
this game i'm studying
every magazine that exists that has
hand-cut rookies in them
so i stumble on them at a thrift store
or a garage sale
yeah like i know the additions of like
sports illustrated for kids or
european stuff or something like i'm
doing the work
which is like the complete reverse of
what a lot of people think i'm doing
which is like
something like i'm going harder than the
people that are making fun of me that
they go hard no and i definitely
appreciate that i appreciate anyone who
puts the effort
yeah exactly thanks tyler and and so i
guess let me with the finished thought
is
the two things i love the most is
physically hunting
garage sales thrift stores and
virtually hunting living in sgc
beckett and psa pop reports and then
looking for weird stuff that i think say
to myself okay so wait a minute
so if i'm right about vintage basketball
which now has been proven to be true
this is me two years ago
well then there's a trickle-down effect
if 57 russell
and 61 oscar and 69 jabar
al cinder go up 10x like i think it will
what are the other collateral things
that will move because of that and
that's what stumbled me and i see bear
like these are [ __ ] dope
awesome it's um awesome set and i think
it's gonna go through the roof
because i also think a lot of
advertising people and antiquers
like cards are gonna get big big it's
not just sneaker kids it's gonna be
lawyers
it's gonna be ad executives and the
advertising executives from my world
they're going to think an icy bear or
sugar daddy or carvel
or gatorade collaboration card is
actually cooler than the accepted hobby
tops or flea rookie
yeah that that's what i think actually i
love the obscure [ __ ] that you can't
find like uh
there's a set it was made in the late
60s i forget the name of it was made in
wisconsin
by a hot dog company i can't remember
the name starts then
you mean uh cons in ohio yeah yeah
yeah that's what i was thinking but you
said f i was like
yeah and again this is what i'm proud of
tyler you know what kind of great moment
this is for me
you're deeply respected and educated in
the game
and you bring up something and i can
name the set like i'm doing my work
yeah and i appreciate that i mean that i
mean
like if i was really doing this just so
everybody just so everybody knows
what it's going to look like the bad
version of me
here's what it's going to look like
they're going to pick a high production
current thing
that is low cost buy them like crazy and
then
so you would pump the 13
uh what what pick was giannis 13 do you
guys know
fourteen fourteen i think fourteen
percent i think
if we're gonna do that move you're gonna
take the 14th this is a weird draft
there was no march madness
it's super weird so one could clean
here's what they're going to do they're
going to clean that this is a weird
draft and they didn't
do the same kind of work and that you
love the 14th player in the draft
they're going to load up on 14th player
for [ __ ] months
the production of [ __ ] prison next
year is going to be through a billion
no i do not blame them if they keep
selling and and
they're going to load up and that's what
they're going to pump with no data with
no
on the court not [ __ ] hey i think
rare things that look like antiques and
art that there's only 39 of
have a shot not lebron i got [ __ ] on for
lebron james rookie
how do you get [ __ ] on for that yeah
like
does anybody understand devin booker's
numbers plus i knew
which is why i've been scoping the whole
time what devin booker thinks about fame
and floss so i knew he was also out and
cared about that
i knew the kendall thing was inevitable
i didn't know it was ken but that
matters
there's for fame like so like
i just that's for anybody who's
listening right now like
listen i understand everything but i do
think the merit
of a man's words should be part of the
equation and i find it very difficult
if you look carefully jordan stickers
like akeem elijah one like look at every
piece of content i put out
luca like i i like
i don't know man i don't know
like my theory like what i just said i
think it's logical
like when you bring up some obscure
thing i know it's cons like i'm on my
[ __ ]
you know i know that basketball vintage
goes through the roof you got to look at
football vintage because what's going on
this doesn't make sense
you know like like i don't know man i i
but i do know this tyler and jack and
nate
i got [ __ ] on in the liquor business
when i first got into it this internet's
a fad
he's just a kid sasha you shouldn't let
your kid do these things
you're gonna go out of business and then
i became yes i know that when i started
doing social media
everyone said you've lost your mind the
[ __ ] is this my space is stupid
it's for kids and then i become a genius
yeah by the way i'm
listening quote unquote i don't think
i'm a genius then i start an advertising
agency
everybody shits on me what does the wine
guy know about that
then [ __ ] vayner happens right let me
tell you what was happening in my life
when i was getting [ __ ] on by everybody
in the card industry
everybody was [ __ ] on me in the real
life business world of i've lost my mind
cards are stupid like
ultimately the reason i'm able to be
empathetic and can understand opinions
is i know my opinion of myself
and your opinion of me actually don't
matter what matters is what ends up
happening to be true
yeah yep
well wow i can't believe we actually did
this to be honest
a lot when tyra said he got you i was
like
really we're doing this i enjoyed it i
hope everybody's having fun
if you enjoy this interview hit me up on
twitter and instagram i can't wait to
meet every single one of you on card
shows around the country once we can do
it
yeah i love engaging all of you and and
i really appreciate the opportunity
gang and we'll talk soon oh yeah
pleasure appreciate it so much
thank you so much take care hey
everybody on youtube first of all thank
you so much so humbled for your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out